[Music]
on average one-third of people's waking
hours are spent using their phone as
they look at it five times every hour
for a total of 85 times a day we are not
only changing our phones every two hours
but our phones are changing us to make
sure you watch this video until the end
to find out how your phone could end
your life if you love your phone as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you that this is
what happens when you stop using your
phone your phobia with the popularity of
cell phones came a new propia called
nomophobia the no mobile phone phobia
people suffer from anxiety when they
can't use their phone most of them
depend on their phones to complete basic
tasks and they don't know how they would
do all these things without it others
have a fear of missing out when they are
not connected to the rest of the world
there is so much information on our
phones that we feel like we are missing
a part of our brain when it's not in our
hand and don't think that most people
could easily take a cellphone vacation
whenever they want
58 percent of men and 47 percent of
women suffer from nomophobia and 9% more
at least those stress when they're
separated from their phone two and three
people sleep with their smartphones and
one-third admitted that they answered
their phones during an intimate moment
with their partner but it gets worse one
in five people would rather go without
shoes for a week than take a break from
their phone and more than a half never
switch off their phones it might be
difficult for you to stop using your
phone as you might feel really stressed
but you will feel much better after
fighting it nomophobia we are not
telling you that you should never use it
but turning off during an activity or
while you're on vacation can help you
feel happier without it okay guys we are
so excited to announce we're producing
our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section you love to
hear from you see you there your
addiction turning off your phone might
not be as easy as you think because many
people don't only suffer from No More
phobia they are also addicted some
students tried to go through the whole
day without using their phones and only
50% of them were able to do it because
the others were suffering from some kind
of withdrawal symptoms some of them said
that it felt similar to a phantom limb
while others said that they felt their
phone vibrating even though they didn't
have it on them and others even admitted
that media was their drugs they feel
lost without and even think that they
are addicted and if you are playing
games it can even get worse you probably
already know that candy crush is one of
the most addictive games and they know
exactly what they need to do to trick
your brain the game is so simple that
even a kid can play it but every time
you accomplish something its experienced
as a mini reward in your brain it
releases dopamine which makes us feel
better and encourages us to do the same
thing again dopamine has a huge impact
on our behaviors and can even change our
habits to the point that we become
addicted the leading useless apps that
make you feel addicted is the first step
towards recovery your posture when we
spend most of our days looking at our
phone our computer and our television it
can have a big impact on our body spine
surgeons noticed that more patients
suffer from neck and upper back pain
related to the poor posture that they
have when they're using their phones
young patients who shouldn't have any
problems are now suffering from
discourteous and alignment problems in
an x-ray you would usually see the neck
curving backward but it's actually doing
the opposite now that mobile phones are
more popular than ever but you don't
have to worry too much because there is
a 20 second cure for the smartphone neck
and all you need is your own hand sit up
with your back straight and your head
right above your ribcage
you need to push against the side of
your head while keeping it straight and
hold it for five seconds your head
shouldn't move you just want to meet
your own strength then repeat the same
thing with each side of your head by
doing this every day you will feel much
more comfortable in your body but the
best thing to do is to simply stop using
your phone anyway if you ever find the
strength to do that you won't even need
a phone to call the spine surgeon you're
asleep if you're not able to sleep at
night your phone might be the problem
scientists found out that the more you
use your phone the more likely you are
to have poor sleep quality and less
sleep overall and it just gets worse
when you use your cell phone near
bedtime and this is actually when people
are using it the most one thing that
could explain this is the blue light
coming from mobile phones and computer
screens it can suppress our body
production of melatonin which is a
hormone that induces tiredness and also
contributes to the timing of sleep wake
cycles it stimulates you and makes you
think that it's not the right time to
sleep right now this can have a huge
impact on your health as being deprived
of sleep can cause our body systems to
fail it has an impact on our performance
our memory and our attention span but
also our immune and endocrine system a
lack of sleep is also a risk factor for
diabetes obesity depression and
cardiovascular diseases Apple recently
added a night setting to avoid the blue
light and you can also buy glasses that
will work like a filter to help you
sleep better but the best thing to do is
simply to stop using your phone at night
try that for a week and you'll see a big
difference your brain we already talked
about the impacts that our cell phone
has on our memory it acts just like an
external hard drive and this is why we
feel like we were missing a part of our
brain when we don't have access to it
having access to information simply by
doing a little research and our
smartphone also reduces our motivation
and ability to remember things as we
know that Google will always have the
answer but that's not the only in
we have in our brain a study found out
that using your phone for 50 minutes
significantly increases your brain
activity some people say that heavy
mobile phone users have 40% more chances
of having brain cancer but this study is
still controversial we do know that
using a cell phone for a long time does
have a direct impact on the brains
metabolism but this is not the reason
that it has carcinogenic effects for now
experts say that just because the brain
is stimulated doesn't mean that it's a
health risk we still need more studies
to be done before we can finally get the
real answer no matter what if you don't
want to take any risk we suggest you
only use your phone when you really need
to otherwise you can at least say that
not using your phone will have a
positive impact on your memory your
health earlier in this video we already
told you that the lack of sleep caused
by phones could make you more at risk of
having diabetes obesity depression and
cardiovascular diseases we also know
that spine surgeons reported more
problems with the neck and upper body to
the poor posture of cell phone users and
it might even cause brain tumors even
though it's not proven but that's not
the only thing it can do this sounds fun
but it should actually be taken
seriously experts say that sore thumbs
due to too much texting are now on
modern-day nuisance people suffer from
stress injuries pain numbness and
discomfort some people can also be
allergic to the metal components in
their cellphones and it causes allergic
reactions if they don't know about it if
the music you're listening to is too
loud it can also damage your hearing and
surprisingly health care workers who
work in hospitals are even more at risk
that's because their phones are covered
in germs that are dangerous to human
health after all who thinks about
cleaning up their phones we think that
we will start doing it now that you know
about this or maybe we just won't use a
phone at all however not owning a phone
can actually be bad for your health
how will you call 9-1-1 if
something bad happens your perceptions
your mobile phone doesn't only have an
impact on your body but also on your
perception of the world around you if
you ask you how many times you use your
cell phone every day most of you will
probably say 40 or 50 times like you
actually need to double that number to
be close to the actual number of times
you look at your mobile phone it just
goes to show that we are so addicted
that we don't even notice this anymore
it's an automatic behavior and it's
quite scary when we think about this
using your cell phone also has a
negative impact on your productivity but
not for the reason that you are thinking
about just hearing a notification is a
big enough distraction to make you less
efficient it means that even though
you're not using your phone just having
it in your pocket can disrupt your
performance technology also speeds up
time as our personal time zone is
affected by it and it has an impact on
our internal clock it makes us impatient
for anything that takes more than a
second to achieve we expect everything
to happen as soon as we click on a
button and we are disappointed to see
that it doesn't happen in real life
this is why you better turn off your
phone when you work or if possible not
use it at all you will become much more
productive your security hacking a phone
is much easier than you think all of
your information is there and when you
carry it everywhere with you if you give
people the opportunity to easily have
access to it no matter where you go with
your phone you are making yourself
vulnerable and we know that you are
taking it everywhere with you it's
easier than you think to guess your
password and professional hackers can
easily find many other ways to get what
they want from you simply by hacking
your phone they can have access to your
bank account steal your private pictures
ruin your reputation online and pretty
much everything you would only see in
your worst nightmares we won't tell you
how they are doing this but we can at
least tell you how to make sure that
you're safe always use a password to
make sure that no one other than you has
access to your phone install software
updates as soon as they are available to
make sure that any vulnerability
been patched don't grant any permission
to the apps you are using unless you
really trust them because they can
easily have access to your camera or
your microphone use a fine my device
service in case you lose your phone and
there are still many other things that
you can do when you think about it not
using your phone is probably the safest
option your relationship we all know how
annoying it is when we are trying to
spend more time with our friends but
they won't talk to us because they are
already using their cell phones we have
to admit that we did it before - you
probably think that your phone gives you
the chance to stay in contact with your
friends no matter where you are but it's
actually ruining your relationships if
people are having a conversation while a
phone is nearby they will report lower
relationship quality and less closeness
according to a study so you might have a
new Facebook friend but you probably
won't talk to them anymore and if you do
fall in love anyway it gets worse
almost half of the people who are in a
relationship said that their partner
ignored them because they were too busy
with their phones
22% also think that it had a negative
impact on their relationship many people
said they were less satisfied with their
relationship when their partner was
overly addicted to their mobile phones
it's like they are jealous of the
attention that the phone is getting
while their partner doesn't have time
for them they don't really care about
how much their partner uses their phone
but about how much they need it try to
turn off your phone and let your partner
show you another way to be turned on
your life did you know that too many
lives were already taken by cell phones
and we are not talking about brain
tumors as this theory has nothing
yes but there are many other reasons why
mobile phones can be dangerous talking
on the phone or taxi is now illegal in
many countries because it's too
dangerous just having a conversation
reduces the amounts of brain activity
devoted to driving by 37% so imagine
what it's like when you are not even
looking at the road anymore it won't
stop 80% of people from using their
phones while driving anyway and even if
you don't have a car using your phone
while crossing the street can be really
dangerous a study proved that talking on
the phone can make you 43 percent more
at risk of being hit by a car is it
really worth it and it just becomes
ridiculous when we hear that more than
70 people passed away in 2016 when they
were trying to take a selfie when we
think that being addicted to our phone
can make us do such dangerous things we
think that we will live a happier life
without it this is why you could live
for a longer time if you stopped using
your phone but how long can you last
without looking at your mobile phone
make sure you tell us in the comment
section down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for this is what happens when
you stop using your phone for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
new secret phone settings that will
surprise you thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]